this kind of setup really is just like
we would look out before except i'm just
looking for something different i'm
looking for an angle instead of looking
for our side okay so i'm going to use
the same idea though because the sine
rule tells me just as much about angles
as it does about science so i'm going to
write the same idea up with one subtle
difference remember here i'll just point
out to you this first line of an actual
working in here right see how i
purposely put the X there at the top
left to make it easiest for me so i
don't have to rearrange things all that
kind of thing x is what i want to solve
so that's why i put it front and center
okay now here i'm trying to find an
angle my side so instead of writing and
sign a be on time be i'm just going to
write the whole thing upside down okay
instead of a on sunday all right sign a
all day and all right side be on me it's
exactly the same rule and just rearrange
here I'm manipulating a little bit just
to make it easier to find what I'm are
done okay so I've got sign a on a equals
sign be on let me just make a quick note
about writing formulas I think it's
always handy to write formulas the
formulas themselves without any actual
values from the question first not
because that formula gets you any marks
but because write it for your dad in
exactly the way that you remember it
helps you write the next step clearly
and accurately okay so it's not like a
meritorious line like hey I wrote down
the formula don't deserve something for
that like no I'm writing that down so I
can do this next step correctly and not
accidentally rearrange ap so sign a
that'll be this angle that I want x z y
less so i'm going to one side of X said
one okay and just like the fall I'm
going to match up officer features if it
helps you here's another color and
literally draw a cross the lines arrows
to match up and
news with their opposite side you see
that angle with the rub society so 28.6
is going to do this in on the interview
and one side moving on to the right-hand
side I need the other pair right so i
will get another color yes I don't sorry
I've got my angle on the top so here's
my other angle right 121 sign 121 / and
i'll look at conveniently the only thing
left which is the opposite side right so
that's 38.5 okay having land all of this
up I'm ready to move on to the next step
which is just like what I had before
let's write this all down together that
I've got sine of X Z Y and what I want
to put into my calculator is this
multiply that guy across and good luck
now once you pop them to calculate I'm
going to the same as well 28.6 so don't
forget to close any brackets that your
calculator inserts for you okay what are
you getting okay now if I just hit
equals on this before I get to that I'm
getting a decimal our time getting this
0.63 blah blah blah blah blah okay now
you look at this and clearly i mean its
angle is small but it's not that small
okay so 0.6 36 is not the angle its sine
of the angle and of course we remember
sine is always between negative 1 and 1
that's how we're getting is the small
value okay so I'm actually just going to
put that step in there sine x z y equals
zero point and yeah 6-3 6-7
etc ok so that's their my calculator
while it's still there I don't what side
the angle adjust what the angle so what
am I going to do my hair yeah I want to
get rid of the side so long ago sine
inverse bays and shift button and then
you pop your answer it and you get an
angle ok so if we go what am I giving it
to you that's your nearest you know
nearest degree ok so we're getting X Z Y
being 30 9.55 blah blah blah blah blah
right so now I will approximate there to
the nearest unit now again pause does it
look good does it make sense like I did
here I get a common sense check right
that number made sense here does this
number make sense here I think it does I
think it looks good you're like yeah
that's about 40 you'd expect this angle
to be smaller because the side opposite
is also smaller ok so happy times right
hmm maybe